alors déjà selim c'est vrai que tout le
monde se pose une question
c'était quand la dernière fois vous
aviez vu votre père on l'avait vu avec
holly en prison un petit salon c'était
en 2000 16 janvier 2016 2005 2007
d'accord il 16 2016 d'accord quand il
était avec vous au début ma part connu
un si beau la demoiselle n'avait pas
reconnu
d'accord au début était distant après il
a commencé à s'approcher un petit peu
mais reste évasif
oui lutte envoyer des piques quand même
hein il a été très sympa avec ses lignes
acérées qu'est-ce qu'il va y regarder il
a dit ça sert à rien d'avoir les
biskotos de tarzan si on a rien dans le
cerveau un certain moment ces lignes lui
demandait ce que je t'ai manqué durant
toutes ces années il lui répond non t'es
pas omniprésent dans mes pensées et non
ouais il était toujours sympathique 15
galas incroyable qu'est ce que ça vous a
fait d'apprendre la mort de votre père
soulagé
l'objection la gym j'espère pour les
proches des familles reconnues
oui mais après moi je suis comme désolé
pour les personnes les familles des
victimes n'ont retrouvé assez ça c'est
ceux qui n'ont jamais été à vous est
possible si c'est un drame pour pour des
familles la mort de michel fourniret
non pas parce qu'il ya une tristesse qui
ce qu'ils soient partis mais qui ne
seront jamais peut-être la vérité 80
fait en tout cas c'est ce alliés
potentiels potentiellement à quelque
temps à faire 80 à faire en tout avait
été celle d'un groupe de musique selim
parce que c'est je crois que c'est un
des seuls fils qui peut dire je suis
soulagé par la mort de mon père c'est à
dire mais oui comment vous l'avez appris
j'ai eu notification sur téléphone ah
ouais nautique sur tf1 michel fourniret
sous respirateur ouais un pronostic fin
de vie engagée quelques heures après
j'ai reçu une notification pour me dire
et man
ce matin la police l'a lui a téléphoné
pour lui demander s'il acceptait de
prendre en charge les frais pour la
sépulture
c'est ça oui évidemment c'est ce que je
voulais savoir justement parce que vous
avez dit quoi que la fosse commune a
très bien d'accord et encore c'est dans
mes siens c'est un témoignage très fort
e vous quand vous avez appris sa mort
vous attendez vous y attendiez un peu ou
pas du tout vous à vous l'espériez en
fait secrètement c'est pas que
j'espérais ou que je m'attendais je ne
pensais pas j'ai appris dernièrement
qu'il avait été hospitalisé en avril il
me semble après j'ai pas une nouvelle je
ne suis pas intéressé et il est mort ben
bon débarras c'est surtout ça fait des
frais en moi pour les contribuables
mais après c'est dommage enfin c'est pas
dommage façon il na jamais ne parle pas
mais nous en prison nous avouer de deux
meurtres mais après il pas l'injustice
et bâle les enquêteurs est ce qu'il nous
avait parlé un jour sert à changer que
quelque chose pour vous sa mort ou
sorties n'ont su soulager vraiment mieux
oui c'est ça fait la seule fois que lui
il veut aller se promener
il appelle la juge ait dit je vous
parlais j'ai des choses à vous dire il
va se promener dans les bois
moi on me convoque pour me dire est ce
que vous vous rappelez en janvier 95 ce
que ce que michel a fait moi je dis je
fais aux enquêteurs et au juge je veux
faire ma vie tranquillement je veux tu
ne peux pas être tiré un trait là dessus
donc monique olivier maintenant je pense
que va pas faire profil bas
on n'a pas parlé va rester tranquille
dans son coin les comptes qui se
résumait de michel ils vont jamais être
inquiété parce que la saône et convoque
michel c'est terminé j'espère être
tranquille à présent justement orioli
santoro est ce que est ce que on peut
avoir
monique olivier qui se décide à parler
maintenant le problème c'est que elle
tente à travers ces pseudos déclarations
de s'humaniser ce qu'elle espère on a
tous deviné c'est une réduction de peine
mais quel crédit apporter à ce qu'elle
raconte
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu beaucoup d'effet
d'annoncé sur la sphère mouzin on attend
toujours tous les trois mois on nous
fait le coup des fouilles et toujours
rien quoi donc
est ce qu'elle disait la vérité ou est
ce qu'elle cherche simplement à
s'humaniser c'est ce que pense le
docteur ployer qui est le
ce psychiatre qui avait expertisé michel
fourniret il faut faire très attention à
ce qu'elle raconte parce que de ce
qu'elle veut c'est sortir et d'ailleurs
c'est l'hymne dit que doit-on même si
elle jouera un jour elle réussit elle
réussit à sortir elle trouvera personne
à l'extérieur il ya personne qui
l'attend penser qu'elle a été touchée
par le décès de michel pour 90 la veille
il avait divorcé va donc elle depuis
longtemps donc soulagés ou pense elle
aussi je pense qu'elle est soulagé on
n'est pas en contact n'est pas
comparable dans le contact par mois on
peut peut pas donc s'attendre à de
nouvelles révélations de monique olivier
hahn monique olivier mais vous savez il
ya toujours des gens à l'extérieur qui
ont très bien connu fournir et ouais
qu'on n'a jamais auditionnés c'est ce
qu'on a révélé dans ce livre c'est ce
que nous a dit mi chowdhary robin le
fils de loeb chez durant notre longue
relation épistolaire
oui il a parlé c'est l'espace qui voit
là ils pensaient nous ce qu'on a fait en
fait c'est qu'on a essayé de manipuler
le manipulateur autoproclamé j'ai
demandé à selim sylla qu'il consentait à
écrire sont pas dicter ce qu'il a
accepté de faire et pendant quatre ans
on à écrire à michel fourniret je me
suis fait passer pour selim en gros quoi
bien sûr qui nous a permis d'installer
un langage codé il s'est beaucoup confié
il a confié des noms voilà et même des
hommes politiques qu'ils fréquentaient
c'était loin d'être l'homme décrit par
stéphane bourgoin le serial menteur quoi
c'est quelqu'un qui avait le bras très
longue avec beaucoup d'amis qui avaient
des relations avec des gens très hauts
placés dans l'armée j'ai cité le service
secret 11e choc bagheera bagheera en
référence au livre de la jungle
la panthère noire et le surnom de
fourniret dans l'intimité c'était quand
même sherkan alors est ce que c'est un
hasard ou est ce que c'est des langages
codés de militaire il a essayé tous ces
gens qui ont été qui ont côtoyé fournir
et pendant toutes ces années là plus
d'impunité savent peut-être quelque
chose
moi je sais qu'il fréquentait un
vénérable maître que j'ai interviewés
pour les besoins de l'enfer des arrières
vous pouvez l'invite à retrouver
l'interview là dedans le mec se vante de
ne jamais avoir été auditionné parce
qu'il est protégé par ses appartenances
à savoir l'armée le grand orient de
france car on est où là on parle
d'enfants quand même qu'est ce qu'on
attend pour auditionner ce type ça le
premier aujourd'hui un voisin qui sort
et qui dit ou d'enquêteurs oui j'ai eu
une vision mystique
estelle mouzin et peut-être enterrés là
bas et celle ci est pris au pied de la
lettre c'est quand même bizarre
le problème par rapport à ça parce que
quand on en parle on a dit c'est
n'importe quoi c'est vrai
c'est tout de suite la formation de riz
tout de suite les grands des grands noms
campano enquêteurs on dit oui d'accord
mais après on voit que ça évolue pas
qu'à paris a pas de provocation n'ya pas
de suivi on voit que toujours à chaque
fois on en parle comme un fort et s'est
isolé comme un celi madame à des
révisions et bien sûr est ce que vous
arrivez à vivre normalement maintenant
est-ce que ce que vous êtes heureux
non mais c'est ce que vous êtes heureux
oui je suis je suis en deuil
super en deux je suis je suis bien j'ai
ma vie on ne reconnaît pas je suis voilà
comme je dire dans la foi c'est une
fournir il est mort maintenant michel
fourniret les morses et puis c'est un
mensonge quand je dis mais je suis
heureux oui bernard montiel
juste un mot je voudrais quand même
rappeler que c'est monique olivier qu'il
avait fait plonger pascal il était sorti
de prison en 1987 suite à 12 agressions
sexuelles et il sortait prison et c'est
là qu'ils se sont mariés d'ailleurs
puisqu'elle lui avait écrit en prison
etc
et quand ils ont réussi à le faire
plonger suite à ses déclarations à l
donc moi j'espère que monique au lit
mais va parler parce que c'est elle même
qui a donné des indications sur où et où
sort et estelle mouzin et j'espère qu'il
va continuer de paris mais si voilà si
ils sont ils sont mieux un petit peu
mieux placé que nous je pense qu'on
savoir s'il va parler ou pas oui oui
j'avais une question sélima à quel
moment parce que ce qui est terrible
quand on regarde toutes les mines votre
père il démarre sa première pression est
à l'âge de 25 ans a déjà un pour
attouchements sexuels et viols il sera
condamné de trois fois j'ai juste une
question à vous poser à quel moment vous
êtes au courant de pied votre père à
quel âge vous avez à quel moment de
votre vie c
après son arrestation en 2003 monuc n'a
pas voulu me dire exactement de quoi
pourquoi il a été arrêté
c'est après la télé j'ai vu qu'il avait
enlevé une suis dit c'est que c'est vrai
l'année suivante
quant à monique avec les révélations sur
les meurtres et est tout ce qu'il ya vu
que j'ai appris la vérité sur ce qu'il
était